bonsoir et bienvenue en municipal 2014
ce soir nous allons nous intéresser aux
communes de saint-cière l'école et des
clés sousbois avec mes invités nous
évoquerons également la candidature du
maire sortant de versaill François de
maierre et puis les deux candidats qui
sont en list à Bois d'Arcy mais donc
d'abord direction saint-cre d'école
jeanve Maximilien bonsoir bonsoir vous
mènerez sur cette commune une liste
Front de gauche je rappelle que vous
êtes élu de l'opposition depuis 2008 au
au sein de la liste saint-ir avantçon
ensemble liste menée dirigée par Daniel
Gerson qui est lui-même candidat et en
2008 je rappelle qu'il y avait trois
listes à saint-cière l'école et Bernard
Debain avait été élu dès le premier tour
alors d'abord comment vous observez
cette vie politique à saint-cière
l'école parce que là pour ce scrutin de
2014 il y a beaucoup plus de listes il y
a notamment la liste du ma sortant
derard de bain il y a à droite centre il
y a celle d'Étienne et rassimus et
Gaetane des jardins et puis à gauche il
y a celle de Daniel garçon et puis la
vôtre c'est vrai que c'est une
configuration un peu
particulière je pense que bon à droite
c'est leur problème he je dirais c'est
c'est pas mon camp alors on va du coup
Daniel Garson et vous n'avez pas réussi
à faire alliance pourtant vous êtes au
sein du même groupe dans l'opposition de
municipal oui bah écoutez on a on a des
différences à un moment donné il faut
les assumer pleinement et voilà bon il y
aura de de listes de gauche pour ce
premier tour vous pas peur que les
électeurs soient un peu perdu ben je
pense que comprennent pas la limite
pourquoi vous siégez au conseil
municipal à côté et pourquoi mais je je
pense que les électeurs font la
différence on a des appréciations
différentes sur un certain nombre de
domaines notamment sur l'azac renard
dont on va parler peut-être tout à
l'heure sur la démocratie et la
démocratie la participation citoyenne
sur l'appréciation que l'on peut avoir
de la situation nationale et de ce que
ça implique au niveau local
comme contrainte hein
puisque le PS au gouvernement nous en
sert dans un étau nous les citoyens et
également les collectivités
territoriales et notre point de vue à
nous c'est qu'il faut sortir de euh ça
sert à exprimer ses idées et puis à se
positionner en vue en vue d'une alliance
au second tour pe tout à fait absolument
bonir en 2008 on a eu un une seule liste
et elle a récolter 35 % des voix ce
n'est pas
satisfaisant Debain avait été élu au
premier tour d'ailleurs avec Mme malgré
tout trois listes il avait quand même
été au premier tour on va revenir sur
les les dossiers de saint-ci l'école je
voudrais d'abord une réaction sur la
Tangentielle ouest puisque le préfet a
déclaré en fin de semaine dernière a
déclaré l'utilité publique la première
phase qui doit relier Saint-Germain onl
à saint-cier l'école c'est quelque chose
qui était vraiment très attendu vous
êtes satisfait oui c'est vrai que c'est
une c'est une satisfaction par contre
cette ce projet ne va pas jusqu'au bout
puisque les deux pôles
de d'emplois que sont Versailles et sain
ne seront 51 pardon ne seront pas
desservis par cette tangentielle ce qui
est un ce qui est dommageable nous ce
que l'on pense c'est que dans le cadre
de l'arrivée de cette tangentielle sur
saint-y il faut absolument que l'on
repense complètement la gare de saint-cy
pour en faire un pôle multimodal de
façon à accueillir les transports en
commun par bus des vélos et cetera
d'autres types de
transport vra gare
routière c'est ce qui manque à sair et
ce qu'on a comme projet de façon à
pouvoir je dirais drainer les gens qui
aujourd'hui prennent leur voiture pour
aller à la gare de saint-ire il faut
qu'ils y arrivent par bus avec des
circulations en site propre sur la rue
Gabriel Perry par exemple sur la rue
pierrecur mais dans le plan local de
déplacement il y a c'est inscrit ces
circulations douces mais pas
suffisamment alors c'est d'une part
c'est mais d'autre part ça ne se fait
pas donc nous on on va faire en sorte
que ça se fasse le plus tôt possible en
s'appuyant notamment sur les habitants
certaines associations locales ont
construit les projets qui recoupent on
va dire ce PLD et il faut je dirais
agréger ces différents projets pour
aboutir et aboutir rapidement ça ces
habitants pour l'instant ils sont pas
écoutés exactement pas demandé leur avis
parce que ça se absolument cé euh
l'association récopique que je peux que
peux je peux citer a fait un travail
énorme de je dirais compilation de de
projection et cetera depuis une dizaine
d'années même plus de presque 15 ans ce
travail n'a jamais été porté par les
élus même les élus à saincir ne l'ont
pas écouté hein ils ont ils ont fermé
les portes à l'association depuis euh
depuis que la droite est au pouvoir à
saincir donc nous
ce que l'on pense c'est qu'il faut
écouter les saintsyriens écouter
notamment cette association et l'aider à
porter jusqu'au bout ce projet de
boulevard urbain sur la rue piercur al
ça m'envent à parler de une de vos
premières priorités c'est la démocratie
citoyenne estimez qu' effffectivement
assassin d'école la parole est pas assez
donnée aux habitants mais j'ai envie de
venir par exemple sur la zacrenard il y
a eu quand même plusieurs réunions de
concertation il y a eu plusieurs
réunions de concertation mais en fin de
compte on s'est concerté sur la place
des pot de fleurs je dirais ça a été
très marginal c'était des réunions par
thème c'était r c'est vrai mais
euh n'a jamais été posé le pourquoi de
temps de logement euh le le pourquoi du
fait que la commune ne met pas un €o
dans le projet ça c'est des questions
qui n'ont pas été posées et où les Saci
NT pas eu mais vous pensez que c'est le
rôle d'un habitant d'avoir un avis à
donner sur sur le financement d'un
projet de dire bah après tout tant mieux
si la commune met pas d'argent dedans
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt bien pour les
oui alors je j'ai pas ce point de vue là
je pense que à partir du moment où la
commune ne met pas 1 € dans
l'affaire aucun moyen de contrôle de ni
du planning ni de la façon dont ça va se
s'organiser en terme de construction de
type de logement et cetera la commune de
saincir a engrangé un pactol qui est
aujourd'hui de 11 millions d'euros sur
un budget
total effectif de 20 d'une vingtaine de
millions d'euros euh donc c'est énorme
c'est un pactol que les saint-yiens ont
payé mais dont ils n'ont pas la
compensation je dirais en service public
et avec ces 11 millions d'euros la
commune pourrait avoir un moyen de
d'agir au niveau de la ftrp pour pouvoir
peser sur les choix et sur les
orientations et elle ne se donne pas les
moyens et c'est une faute en tant que
direction municipale c'est une faute
grave vous aimeriez voir quoi sur cette
sur cette zacrenur alors en terme de
logement le projet aujourd'hui consiste
à construire pratiquement uniquement du
logement en accession libre nous ce que
l'on pense et
d'ailleurs ce qui est intéressant c'est
que nous avons un allié de de poids
c'est le président de la ftrp qui
récemment dans les échos a à peu près la
même position que nous il faut c'est
l'agence foncière de la région
parisienne je sais plus le T technique
je crois technique AG technique de la
région parisienne voilà et donc monsieur
Lajoie dit qu'il est prêt à faire en
sorte que le foncier baisse pour pouvoir
construire le logement social sur les
terrains libres de la région parisienne
et donc nous ce que l'on pense c'est que
pour avoir une vraie mixité sociale dans
ce quartier ce qui est un quartier qui
est très important c'est pratiquement 20
% de la population de saint-cy il faut
qu'il y ait à peu près un/ers de
logement à loyer modéré un/ers de
logement en accession sociale et un/ers
de logement en accession libre donc vous
vous dites il faut revoir tout à fait
absolument il y a des choses qui sont
déjà signées et engagées oui mais vous
savez aujourd'hui la ftrp on voit bien
met la douce au développement
elle sait bien qu'il y a des échéances
et elle sait bien qu'il y a sûrement des
choses qui vont être revues et je pense
qu'elle elle attend ses échéances pour
voir comment ça va se passer vous avez
parlé du prix du foncier la spéculation
immobilière c'est quelque chose qui vous
inquiète sur sainc l'école mais j'ai
envie de dire un merère n'a pas de
pouvoir sur le prix duimmobilier bien
sûr que si et les propriétaires qui
peuvent nous écouterent se dire bah tant
mieux si les prix montent on problème
c'est que euh les prix montent oui mais
on voit bien sur les immeubles et les
appartements qui sont achetés
aujourd'hui c'est des investisseurs qui
achètent pour une grande majorité et qui
ensuite louent à des locataires et la
majorité des gens qui habitent ces
appartements sont donc des locataires et
évidemment quand un investisseur
investit il a besoin que d'avoir une
certaine rentabilité et les loyers sont
très élevés pour un F3 ça peut aller
jusqu'à 1200 donc peut avoir une action
sur le prix d'un loyer alors il a pas
d'action sur le prix du loyer mais via
le PLU il peut maîtriser le foncier un
peu mieux que ce que se fait que ce qui
se fait aujourd'hui notamment en
imposant des règles qui fasse en sorte
qu'on ait des logements sociaux et des
un un un comment dire un seuil de de
logements sociaux dans chaque
construction ça c'est possible et ça ça
orienterait la spéculation à la baisse
merci Jean Maximilien d'être venu sur le
plateau de de TV F de municipale 2014
vous avez aussi d'autres priorités et
vous pourrez certainement discuter avec
les autres candidats puisqu'un débat
sera organisé sur la commune de
saint-cierre l'école et qui sera diffusé
sur notre antenne le 18 mars prochain
auquel vous participerez oui bien sûr
merci beaucoup d'être venu
merci allez on poursuit cette émission
maintentin avec la commune de de
boudarciy à l'heure actuelle ils sont
deux à se présenter devant les électeurs
le maire sortant socialiste Claude vuyet
élu depuis 1995 et Philippe benasaya
investi par l'UMP et l'UDI un portrait
signé yolen
Torz maire de boisarcille depuis 19 ans
et arrivé sur la ville en 1969 Claude
vyet est candidat à sa succession après
ses mandats consécutifs de
1995 2001 puis 2008 à 80 ans il se sent
prêt à repartir à la conquête des
bulletins de vote au plan local j'ai pas
j'ai pas d'inquiétude on est c'est mon
j'attaque mon 4e
mandatment un 4è mandat qu'il souhaite
dans la continuité de ses mandats
précédents avec les mêmes objectifs au
sein de sa liste 19 nouveaux arrivants
et l'un de ses projets phares pour cette
campagne c'est ce qu'il appelle la
construction d'un cœur de ville pour
qu'une ville vive bien il faut que les
gens se rend compent la mixité sociale
et puis dans ce projet cœur de ville où
on parle de de résidence
intergénérationnelle il y a une réponse
sur le logement on a la volonté de de de
répondre d'abord à nos obligations qui
sont celles d'aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire
aller à terme à 25 % de logement aidé
donc on a fait beaucoup de progrès
puisqu'on a démarré en 95 avec 3,5 % on
est aujourd'hui à 17 mais il faut
poursuivre ce travail et puis la loi
nous nous impose de faire du logement
aidé donc dans tous nos projets la
mixité sociale et puis la possibilité
pour les arcisiens d'avoir un parcours
résidentiel hein il y en a beaucoup de
choses à faire passer encore mais ça
m'étonne pas ça m'étonne pas bah vous
nous connaissez mais oui non mais vous
êtes je dire ça va être le 3e ou 4
j'attaque le
4e si je peux dire je pense c'est un
homme de terrain enfin j'aime bien les
gens faut aimer les gens à mon avis
quand on veut on veut s'impliquer au
plan local c'est tout à fait essentiel
donc ça c'est c'est quelque chose que je
que je vis bien euh et puis bien
implanté sur la vie enfin il y hein les
enfants les petits enfants Les Amis
enfin on connaît beaucoup de monde
donc on se plaît j'aime j'aime ma ville
nous aimons notre ville face à lui
Philippe benasaya 49 ans déjà candidat
aux dernières élections municipales en
2008 n'hésitez pas à engager la
conversation les arciens ont besoin de
nous entendre ont besoin d'avoir des
réponses donc je compte sur vous on est
très nombreux ce matin membre de l'UDF
au centre dans les années 80 il rejoint
ensuite l'UMP et se présente aux
élections régionales de 2004 aujourd'hui
il souhaite devenir le prochain maire de
boisarcy et revendique être à la tête
d'une liste sans étiquette
je suis à la tête d'une liste de
rassemblement il y a pas de division
dans notre camp contrairement à à à nos
adversaires nous avons nous une liste
d'union UMP udi divers gauche divers
droite et non inscrit divers gauche
parce qu'il y a aussi des personnalités
de gauche que l'on respecte et que l'on
souhaite mettre sur notre sur notre
liste je suis pas un politicien voilà
c'està-dire que je ne fais pas une liste
à bois d'Arc pour faire de la politique
j'ai mes convictions mais je ne pense
pas que les convictions rentrent dans le
projet d'une ville faire une école faut
pas être de gauche ou de droite pour
faire une école il faut qu'elle soit
belle il faut qu'elle accueille les
enfants donc j'ai mes convictions elles
sont personnelles c'est même presque du
domaine du privé mais non notre liste
c'est une liste de rassemblement des
compétences arcisiennes et à ce titre je
n'ai pas envie de me priver de
compétences qu'elle soit de droite ou de
gauche ça ça m'est égal fervante
opposant au projet du maire sortant cœur
deeville Philippe benassa arrivé sur
bois d'Arc en 2008 axe sa campagne sur
la défense de la qualité de vie et de
l'environnement
notre premier axe fort c'est le cadre de
vie et le respect de l'environnement la
deuxième chose bien sûr c'est la
maîtrise des impôts locaux qui ont
explosé à boarci et nous souhaiterions
maîtriser les impôts sur 6 ans le trème
point c'est la création d'une police
municipale qui n'existe pas boisar qui
existe dans toutes les autres villes
autour de Bois d'Arcy que soit de droite
ou de gauche mais qui n'existe pas à à
boisarcy et ensuite bien évidemment
c'est moderniser les écoles lancer un
grand plan numérique dans les écoles
pour pouvoir offrir aux enfants des
outils numériques adaptés au 21e
les deux hommes s'affronteront lors du
premier tour des élections le 23 mars
prochain il brille un nouveau mandat le
maire de Versailles François de Maier
élu en 2008 il était l'invité du 78
lactu vendredi dernier il est revenu
notamment sur la division de la droite
pour ce prochain scrutin dans sa commune
lors de ce scrutin à Versailles cela va
peut-être ressembler quand même à une
bataille à droite non avec ces listes
qui émergent petit à petit versaill
famille avenir avec Fabien bouglet benoî
Cernin qui vous a soutenu en 2008 et là
qui qui fait sa propre liste écoutez
c'est vrai que les candéat que vous avez
évoqué sont venus me voir on disons
est-ce qu'on pourrait participer à ma
liste donc c'est je pense que d'une
certaine façon ils sont conscients qu'on
a fait du bon travail parce qu'ils
souhaitit être avec nous après
malheureusement dans une équipe on peut
pas prendre tout le monde aujourd'hui
ils ont le souhait de mener leur propre
aventure ben c'est très bien mais ce qui
est important de savoir c'est qu'au
départ il trou pas que nous avions si
mal travaillé que ça concernant la la
liste versaill famille avenir vous vous
en parliez ils sont venus vous voir ils
vous sollicité Fabien bougl le la tête
de liste cette liste là est-ce que ça
vous priverait pas d'une partie de votre
électorat parce que c'est quand même il
y a quand même quelques points communs
non il y a beaucoup de points communs
sur la famille c'est vrai que nous nous
avons beaucoup travaillé sur ce terrain
de la famille et puis en tant que
parlementaire je m'étais engagé à
défendre ces sujets et vous savez je
crois que d'ailleurs personne le
conteste et famille le conteste pas je
me suis énormément donné pour là encore
tener les engagements que j'ais pris
auprès des électeurs j'étais très
présent sur ces sujets maintenant si le
sujet famille est essentiel et il sera
essentiel dans les 6 ans qui vont venir
si les versillaers renouvellent la
confiance à mon équipe ce n'est pas le
seul sujet et là je suis désaccord avec
cette liste parce que tout est axé sur
ce seul sujet puis avant recevoir
Jean-Michel Gourdon candidat au clés
sousbois cette dernière cette autre
précision dans notre dernière édition de
municipale 2014 le président
départemental du Front national Philippe
Chevrier pardon candidat sur ambouiller
avait déclaré en parlant de Jean-Luc
trottignon candidat diviv gauche aussi
sur ambouillet il a autant de
difficultés que moi je pense même un peu
plus il parlait de constitution de liste
et bien jeanluc Trotignon a réagi
immédiatement en nous précisant qu'il
avait bien présenté sa liste à la presse
le 25
janvier
Jean-Michel Gourdon bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes candidat au cl sousbis investi par
le Parti socialiste mais également vous
avez le soutien d'Europe écologie des
Verts du PRG et du Parti communiste
voyez ça fait ça fait pas mal
d'investiture et de soutien vous êtes
élu au clésousbois depuis 1989 vous avez
été pendant 2 ans adjoint de l'ancien
maire communiste 12 ans pardon adjoint
l'ancienne maire communiste Janine
Thomas adjoint à la voirie à l'action
sociale vous êtes depuis 13 ans dans
l'opposition municipale et puis
parallèlement j'ai envie de dire vous
êtes aussi conseiller général depuis
2004 en 2008 CQ listes avaient été
déposé au prier tour et au second tour
vous étiez déjà candidat en 2008 t de
tête de liste et au second tour vous
avez été battu seulement de 216 voix par
la maire actuelle Véronique côté Millard
qu'est-ce qui à votre avis peut changer
pour ce scrutin ça est-ce qui peut
changer disons faire tourner les les
résultats en notre faveur c'est le
nombre de liste si il y a autant de
listes qu'en 2008 évidemment le le
risque sera le même la multiplicité des
listes la
division peut conduire à la défaite là
il y a une dynamique vous venez d'en
parler je suis soutenu donc par les
partis de gauche la liste est
représentative donc des partis de gauche
elle rassemble également des descléiens
du milieu associatif du de la société
civile et donc je pense que ce
rassemblement correspond vraiment à la
sociologie clécienne et aux habitants
des
vous parlez de la possibilité d'autres
candidatures pour l'instant candidat
déclaré il y a vous il y av côté Millard
et là on évoque deux autres candidature
une candidature loutrevrière qui avait
déjà été candidat en 2008 et une
candidature du rassemblement bleu marine
ça vous inquiète ça vous étonne un mois
et demi des municipales euh en ce qui
concerne le Front national je dirais que
ça regarde le Front national moi je ne
je je connais le la tête de liste
pressentie et connu puisque c'est un
ancien coliser de Madame cotémillard
donc que l'évolution est assez étonnante
en ce qui concerne l'ut ouvrière c'est
vrai que c'est une liste qui s'était
déjà présenté en en 2008 euh je pense
que je peux je regrette cette
candidature dans la mesure où ça risque
d'ajouter une division à la gauche euh
bon on verra s'ils vont au bout de leur
projet en tout cas qu' vienent de
déclarer quand même assez tardivement il
reste peu de temps alors avant de parler
de vos priorités sur la commune je
voudrais quand même qu'on revienne sur
le gros dossier des clés sousbois vous
soyiez Z de quoi je parler c'est
évidemment de l'intercommunalité lesclés
fait partie de la même intercommunalité
que plaisir et villepr mais la mère
sortante verni cotéillia elle enfin s'y
oppose franchement estimant que c'est
inutile que le périmè est trop petit que
ce sera finalement trop coûteux pour la
commune et vous quelle est votre
position sur cette
intercommunalité moi je trouve que la
position de Madame le Maire est
incompréhensible en tous les cas je la
conteste dans la mesure où comme vous le
dites elle affirme que ce sera trop
couteau les leseffet démontre le
contraire j'ai j'ai
regardé récemment en ce qui concerne la
dotation globale de fonctionnement
l'attitude de Madame coté a fait perdre
aux habitants de de cette
intercommunalité 13800000 € en 10 ans
puisque la DGF qui aurait été la
dotation globale de fonctionnement
attribué par l'État aux
intercommunalités se serait élevé à
13800000 alors elle s'appu sur le fait
qu'elle serait obligée de de de partager
ces ces recettes économiques et du coup
ce que madame côéard n'a pas compris
c'est qu'il s'agit de coopération pas de
pas de de de réunion à deux contre un
c'est pas la cours d'école c'est réunion
d'élus qui font des choix ensemble
élaborent des projets de manière à
rendre service aux habit elle elle est
plutôt intéressante cette
intercommunalité à trois communes bah
c'est une je dirais que c'est une
intercommunalité de bon sens il suffit
de regarder la carte déjà la carte
Michelin vous avez une tâche brune qui
regroupe ces ces trois communes il y a
une une entité urbaine cohérente les
habitants ce sont les mêmes les les
cléiens les villeespreusiens les
Plaisirois passent d'une ville à l'autre
il y a un certain nombre d'activités qui
sont partagées par les trois communes
nous avons une piscine intercommunale
qui dont on vient de fêter le 40e
anniversaire qui était comment dire il y
a 40 ans les élus de l'époque ont déjà
considéré qu'il était utile de se
regrouper pour des projets donc c'est
utile on va maintenant parler de vos
priorités sur sur la commune une des v
premières priorités ce sont les impôts
ouiugmenté et oui depuis euh 2001 et
depuis 2008 surtout les impôts locaux
ont augmenté dans les proportions
considérables si je compare à nos à nos
deux villes voisines alors que la part
communale des impôts à plaisir et à
villepr n'a pas augmenté au clé et la
augmenté de plus de 12 %. alors demain
vous êtes élu vous faites quoi et bien
je qu' baisser les les taux des taxes
d'habitation je ne baisserai pas les
taux en tous les cas je ne les
augmenterai pas c'estd que le le le
l'engagement de la liste que je conduis
est de ne pas augmenter la part de
communale des des impôts sur la première
année sur sur le mandat il y a des
communes l'ont fait ont réalisé ceci je
pense à Conflant pas mal de de collègues
Mair dans les iblines qui ont réussi à
gérer leur ville dans de bonnes
condition en permettant d'offrir des
services à leurs habitants sans
augmenter la part communale des impôts
locaux autre thème je vrais aborder avec
vous c'est les construction l'urbanisme
vous qui êtes élu depuis 89 et vous
m'avez dit je suis né au clés sousbois
vous avez vu forcément cette ville
évolué est-ce qu'elle a évolué trop vite
oui si vous permettez avant de passer à
ce sujet je voudrais terminer sur la
fiscalité parce que dans le même temps
où Madame cotéillar augmenté les impôts
dans ses proportions l'endettement n'a
pas diminué et toutes les réserves
froncières ont été vendues ce qui fait
que la ville a vécu sur je dirais un
train de VI au-dessus de ces moyens et
il est temps que l'on corrige ceci alors
maintenant ce qui con les constructions
c'est vrai que j'ai j'ai vu la ville
changer mais bon ça c'est la vie je
dirais c'est normal que les villes
évoluent surtout dans nos régions où de
nombreux habitants arrivent et une des
caractéristiques que j'apprécie au clés
sous-bois c'est que cette ville a su
accueillir des habitants de toutes
conditions de toutes de tous horizons et
ceci grâce à l'urbanisme qui a été mené
pendant ces années et parallèlement en
construction un certain nombre de
services étaiit étit mis à disposition
des des habitants ce qui a rendu notre
ville attractive et ce que je regrette
beaucoup parmi les constructions qui
sont réalisées récemment j'entendait
votre l'interlocuteur précédent qui à
saint-sire faisait le le même constat
c'est que spéculation immobilière voilà
on a laisser faire et je pense que pour
pouvoir justement maintenir cette
volonté de d'accueillir tout le monde de
permettre aussi à nos enfants de pouvoir
vivre sur la commune il faut que la
ville se donne les moyens de ça ve dire
ça veut dire quoi vous arrêtez les
constructions non pas du tout il y a
besoin de construction alors au clés les
disponibilités foncières sont sont
réduites hein euh la ville a un espace
limité donc les les constructions
devront répondre à un certain nombre de
d'exigences notamment permettre à à à
tous de pouvoir venir s'y loger et donc
il faut utiliser un certain nombre
d'outils dont les dont les les élus
peuvent disposer de manière à pouvoir
peser sur le prix de sortie des
logements et puis ménager entendait
votre interlocuteur précédent parler du
tiers de l'accession à la propriété du
tiers de location et donc faire des
constructions plutôt mixtes alors voilà
absolument c'est si on veut garder cette
caractéristiqu des clés sous bois c'est
le défi à relever merci beaucoup à
Jean-Michel Gon d'être venu sur le
plateau de municipale 2014 cette
émission est terminée je vous rappelle
que la rédaction propose à partir de ce
jeudi et deux fois par semaine des
débats avec les candidats des communes
de 50 ans niveline et alentour et
premier débat ce sera donc ce jeudi soir
avec la ville de voisin le Bretonneux
bonne soirée à
vous